foreign
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
and in this session we will learn how to
use the between operator in SQL but
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
Technologies if you're a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
Trends then consider getting subscribed
to our YouTube channel and don't forget
to hit that Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn now without
further Ado let's get started with our
one point agenda that is how to use the
between operator in SQL now before we
begin let's try to take a quick look on
the syntax that we will be using today
right it is simply the Select Staff from
table name using the where clause and
the column which you're choosing for
that and the between operator and we are
giving some constraints and those
different constraints are encapsulated
between an and command here let us say
that your manager tells you to select
all the rows where selecting one single
column that is salary where the
employees have the salary three from ten
thousand to twenty thousand right then
you will write the command select star
from table name with salary between the
value 10 000 and the value 20 000. so
this is how the between command works
now let's execute the same practically
let's get back to the MySQL workbench if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now we are back on the MySQL workbench
let's make some edits to the same
command select star from employee where
salary
between operator
so we are using float or integer type so
we will not need a single crochet double
quotes number 10 000. and operator
number twenty thousand
right now let's execute this command
there you go now we have all the
employee list which have or who have
their salary ranging from 10 000 to 20
000. choose from over 300 in-demand
skills and get access to 1 000 Plus
hours of video content for free visit
skill up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more so
that's how you use the between operator
and SQL and with that we have come to an
end of the session on how to use the
between operator in SQL if you have any
queries regarding any of the topics
covered in this session or if you
require the resources like the code used
or the PPT then do let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here